hours before the start of a much
anticipated presidential campaign
president makis makes an unexpected
announcement from the presidential
Palace the cancellation of the election
scheduled for February
25th I will initiate an open National
dialogue to bring together the
conditions for a free transparent and
inclusive election in a peaceful and
reconciled
syal the announcement surprised May
voters who hoped to have a say on their
country's
future he has betrayed the spirit of
dialogue he has betrayed the sagales
people the base of the social contract
is our country's
Constitution we are about to face a
crisis a political crisis and who knows
maybe um uh if the the opposition decide
just to join their Force maybe uh we're
going to face violences a fight in
inside Parliament on Thursday sparked
Sal's decision allies of opposition
leader kareim wad accused constitutional
Court judges who compiled the list of
election candidates of taking bribes to
Bar him from the race judges deny any
wrongdoing opposition MPS voted for a
parliamentary inquiry and called for an
election delay pending the outcome for
wads supporters Sal's decision is a
small victory while there are
celebrations at kareim W's party
headquarters this is a moment of
unprecedented instability in what is
normally known as the most stable
democracy in West Africa Sagal has
experienced only peaceful transitions of
power for the opposition the
announcement is seen as a constitutional
coup a ploy by the president to extend
his 12 years in power 18 election
candidates gathered to denounce the
president's
decision
the hold of Sagal must rise up all
Democratic political forces all forces
of Civil Society should unite to ensure
that this project does not succeed on
the eve of the start of an electoral
campaign it's unacceptable to stop a
process of this nature electoral while
Sal says he won't run in the event of a
new election he has not given a date for
when that will be and for many that's
bringing anxiety and uncertainty to a
nation accustomed to peace and ability
Nicholas hawkk alaz
darar make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from
aler